[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
i can tell you that they are heartbroken
hear from the attorney for brian
laundry's family after remains are found
near his notebook and backpack and a
re-sentence handed down for ex-police
officer mohamed noor i hereby sentence
you to the commission of corrections for
a period of 57
months
plus r kelly placed on suicide watch as
a date is set for his next federal trial
what's next for the disgraced r b singer
and later convicted wife killer scott
peterson denied bail but could be headed
for another trial our legal analysts
break down what's next in his case lawn
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
and welcome everybody to long crime
daily i'm jesse weber in for brian
buckmeyer along with terry austin for a
second day the fbi has searched the
carlton reserve in northport florida
this comes after human remains and some
of brian laundry's personal belongings
were found there long crimes angenette
levy's here to bring us the latest on
the investigation and the newest
comments from the laundry's attorney and
jeanette
you know jesse the head of the fbi in
tampa is now calling brian laundry a
person of interest in gabby petito's
murder and i spoke with the sarasota
county medical examiner dr russell vega
he told me that they are working on
those remains and he doesn't know how
long it will take to identify them
positively
and to make that identification now this
comes as the attorney for the laundry
family tells cnn the probability is
strong that the remains are brian
laundry's but the family is waiting for
a forensic identification before saying
anything more tuesday night steve
bertolino said he notified the fbi that
laundry's parents wanted to search the
maya kahachi creek environmental park
the next morning so they met there
wednesday morning and that's when he
said law enforcement found brian
laundry's backpack
and his remains nearby and chris laundry
found a dry bag belonging to brian the
remains were found near the backpack
according to bertolino as i just
mentioned uh he spoke about all of this
exclusively to cnn
is the area that they were searching
when these
discoveries were made is this a new area
that the parents hadn't informed
authorities about before
no not at all indeed this is the very
area of the park that we initially
informed
law enforcement on
i believe it was september 17th that
brian would be most likely in the
preserve in this particular area as as i
know it near the bridge
and steve bertolino said this was
somewhat near the entrance to the
carlton reserve which has raised a lot
of questions since the fbi and other law
enforcement were there for you know
several weeks scouring this place and
chris laundry actually went out there at
one point in time and was on a gator
with police pointing out areas of
interest the fbi said when making the
announcement about the remains that the
area had been underwater as much of the
rest of the park had been for a time as
well long crime also spoke with forensic
death investigator joseph scott morgan
about what it takes to identify those
remains
i think that that that's certainly
possible remember we'll be able to do
we'll not me they will be able to do uh
dna sampling potentially on the bone
or or any other tissue that's left
behind it all depends on
how intact the sample will be and we've
certainly got a parental sample i i
would suspect that they've probably
already done a buccal mucosal swab on
the parents
at some point time i could have sworn i
saw them going into the residence with
uh with dna swab kits
and they may also be using joseph scott
morgan says dental records to help make
this identification as well again dr
vega is saying they don't know how long
it will take to identify those remains
and when i asked him about the condition
of the remains he said that he couldn't
say any more at this time jesse all
right thanks internet we're joined now
by co-host terry austin and former
federal prosecutor nima romani nima
let's start with you if these are his
remains and they are in a position where
we can determine the cause of death and
the time of death how is that going to
infest affect the investigation moving
forward
well the investigation into laundry will
be done you can't prosecute a dead
person they'll determine if anyone else
was involved with gabby's murder and if
not that's going to close the case i
mean really there may be a civil lawsuit
against his estate that's something that
tito's parents will have to do but on
the criminal side
if it's brian laundry
and if it's confirmed which we all
believe that he was solely involved in
gabby's murder and that's gonna be the
end of it
well terry here's the other part of it
right because at first brian laundry's
parents were noticeably silent
throughout the case and now they were
helping with the search for their son
they were there when the remains and
items were found do you think that they
could face any possible criminal charges
it is very possible jesse that the
parents could face charges they could
face charges of accessory after the fact
for that all you need to show is that a
crime was committed there was knowledge
of that crime and they helped the
individual to avoid arrest and if that's
the case they could also be charged with
obstruction of justice which is also
fairly straightforward you just need an
act that impedes the administration of
justice now you absolutely need to show
that something happened and you just
look at the timeline and you can see the
last time they heard from her gabby was
8 30 and you know so
basically
we know that brian was with his parents
shortly after that so i think that there
was a conversation and they know more
than they're saying and janet real quick
what does the stephen berlin bernalino
and the laundry family attorney say
about them not talking to the fbi police
and the petito family throughout the
search
well he told chris cuomo on cnn that he
told them not to speak to any of those
people so he said you know basically
that's on him he advised them that they
should not speak to law enforcement that
they should not speak to gabby petito's
family and uh you know chris cuomo
followed up saying well you know maybe
that's the legally right thing to do but
how about morally and he he said he
stands by the advice that he gave the
laundry family
fascinating all right thanks anjen i
appreciate it still ahead on law and
crime daily ex-cop mohammed noor
addresses the court just minutes before
he's re-sentenced
i'm
i'm deeply sorry for the pain that have
caused that family
plus the emotional impact statement
given by the shooting victims fiance all
that and more after the break
[Music]
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
the three men charge will now stand
trial for live galado gabo coverage of
the trial subscribe to law and crime on
youtube tv today
[Music]
welcome back to long crime daily
everybody an ex-minnesota police officer
is resentenced to prison time just one
month after the supreme court threw out
his third degree murder conviction
mohamed noor was convicted of the 2019
shooting death of justine rooschick a
911 call of reporting which she believed
was a sexual assault noor a responding
officer to the call said that he fired
his gun because he feared for his
partner's safety he was convicted of
third degree murder but last month's
ruling vacated that conviction on
thursday a minnesota judge sentenced
nord to 57 months in prison on his
remaining second-degree manslaughter
conviction the judge also ruled that
noor will get credit for time served
during thursday's hearing the
prosecution called rooschick's death the
perfect storm as her former fiancee said
that he forgives her shooter and nor
pledged to make a change
on july 15 2017
so many lives changed in a blink of an
eye
two young officers
both early in their careers
both overreacted
and mr neuer's overreaction caused the
tragic death
of miss rooschick and i have no doubt
she would have forgiven you
for your inability to manage your own
emotions
that night
which resulted
in you pulling that trigger
justine was in is
still my greatest teacher
given her example
i want
you to know that i
forgive you
all i ask
is that you use
this experience to do good for other
people
i'm deeply grateful for mr damon's
forgiveness
i'm deeply sorry for the pain that have
caused that family
and i will take his advice
and be a unifier
all right so nemo what's interesting is
the reason that derek shovin was charged
and ultimately convicted of third degree
murder in the george floyd case was
because of noor's third degree murder
conviction which was valid at the time
so now that that charge was thrown out
in nor could chauvin's conviction on
third degree murder be thrown out
yeah i expect it to be thrown out as
well based on the same logic and legal
reasoning right the minnesota supreme
court said that a third degree murder
charge can't be sustained when the
officer or the defendant actions are
directed at a specific individual
and obviously that's what happened with
george floyd and uh derek shelvin and
muhammad noor so i expect that
conviction to be vacated with respect to
just that count only that third degree
murder charges that depraved heart but
it's not going to affect derek chovin's
sentence because in that particular case
he was also convicted of second-degree
murder whereas muhammad noah was not
yeah it might not help him too much
practically terry what are your thoughts
about noor's new sentence it seems kind
of pretty light and do you think he'll
be released soon now
well i think the new sentence for the
lesser charge of that second degree
manslaughter is fairly reasonable
although it does seem as though it's
light the sentencing guidelines call for
41 to 57 months and neither the
prosecution nor the defense asked for a
departure from the guidelines so the
prosecution sought the maximum defense
slot the 41 and the judge said i'm going
to give you the 57. so i think it's
reasonable and he could get out
basically after he has served at least
two-thirds of that sentence pretty
incredible and with time served to think
about getting out pretty soon after a
woman's life was taken it's the law
that's what it is over now to the west
coast a california man is arrested and
charged with his wife's murder ten
months after she went missing on tuesday
forty-year-old larry mayate was charged
with murder and possession of a
semi-automatic rifle in connection to
the death of his wife forty-year-old may
mayate nicknamed maya went missing in
january from her chula vista home she
and her husband had three young children
early on her husband said that he had
nothing to do with the disappearance and
family said that they believed he
wouldn't hurt her but on tuesday the
chula vista police department announced
investigators spent thousands of hours
reviewing the case serving 67 search
warrants conducting 87 interviews and
reviewing hundreds of tips the body of
maya mayate has not yet been recovered
larry maiate is set to appear in court
on thursday
and coming up on lawn crime daily could
another trial be in the works for scott
peterson our legal analyst explains
what's next for the convicted murderer
but first r kelly's plans for next
summer are put on the calendar when the
r b singer will once again face a
federal trial on child pornography
charges stay with us
[Music]
and welcome back everybody another trial
date is set for convicted r b singer r
kelly as his attorneys say he was put on
suicide watch in federal jail on one on
wednesday a judge set an august 2022
court date for kelly's second federal
trial stemming from child pornography
charges and that trial is set to be held
in chicago right now though kelly is
being held in a brooklyn federal jail
after last month's guilty verdict a
federal jury found kelly guilty on nine
counts including racketeering kidnapping
sex trafficking and violating the man
act a federal judge ordered that kelly
remain in custody until his sentencing
in may 2022 for that he faces up to life
in prison now the estranged singer
appeared in court virtually on wednesday
where attorney steve greenberg said that
kelly was briefly placed on suicide
watch following last month's federal
conviction he says kelly showed no signs
he was going to harm himself and he has
since been taken off watch in the in the
upcoming trial out of chicago kelly
faces federal char
charges for child pornography and
obstruction of justice all right let's
bring it back in terry austin and nima
romani okay so nema now that kelly's
attorney out in chicago says that he was
placed on suicide watch after his
federal conviction it makes me wonder is
that something that we commonly see
maybe after such a widely publicized
trial and guilty conviction
yes it's not uncommon i can tell you
that i've put more than a thousand
people in federal prison and you know
this is something that happens all the
time especially for someone like r kelly
who is likely going to die in federal
prison he's looking at a lengthy prison
sentence in the brooklyn case and
probably even more in the chicago case
and there's cases out of minnesota and
georgia as well so there's a lot going
on for r kelly here what about deja vu
terry because r kelly was charged and
acquitted of child pornography back in
2008 do you think the same thing could
happen here could he be acquitted
i do not think he'll be acquitted this
time the evidence in new york was
overwhelming and i think the chicago
prosecution is probably taking notes at
the strategy there and these charges are
very serious the child pornography and
the obstruction of justice and they
carry some very heavy penalties as well
and the other issue here is that maine
witness didn't testify in 2008 and i
think we might get some witnesses who
will testify this time around and
obviously with the metoo movement and
time's up i think people are going to
convict him this time around so he won't
have that deja vu again and for anybody
who thought oh he would never be
convicted he has the shield around him
obviously that is a very different case
now than it was in 2008.
and in other celebrity court news very
different britney spears father is
dropped by his attorneys as the battle
over her conservative ship rages on
jamie spears has now acquired a new
legal team after his original
representation said they fear his
daughter will pursue a lawsuit if and
when the conservatorship is terminated
this comes after the pop star's father
was suspended as the conservator last
month marking a huge milestone in the
so-called free brittany movement this
decision comes after britney spears
attorney matthew rosengard stated that
his firm looks to investigate potential
financial mismanagement from jamie
spears in fact alleging that he profited
off of his daughter's conservatorship
jamie spears has denied allegations of
misconduct during his time as
conservator and brittany is due back in
court on november 12th to address a
possible termination of the
conservatorship last month both sides
filed petitions to end the guardianship
and when we come back scott peterson is
back in the courtroom what ruling a
judge made this week and what the odds
are that he may receive another trial
[Music]
and welcome back everybody jury
selection moves on to day four in
georgia in the trial of the death of a
mod arbory the judge ruling on thursday
that spectators cannot wear items on
their clothing that display political
opinion father and son duo gregory and
travis mcmichael and their neighbor
william bryan face several charges
including malice murder and felony
murder in connection with the death of a
mod arbory in february 2020 the father
and son tailed 25 year old arbory in
their pickup truck while he reportedly
was out for a jog travis mcmichael shot
and killed him claiming self-defense the
father and son plan to cite a citizen's
arrest law but that has since been
repealed and replaced brian the neighbor
followed along and captured the entire
confrontation on his cell phone on
thursday brian's attorney kevin gough
requested that arbory's family leave the
courtroom saying that arbory's father
and other members of the transformative
justice coalition were wearing lapel
pins with logos that could possibly
influence potential jurors the pins had
quotes from the late representative john
lewis saying quote
make good trouble some also wore pins
from the rainbow coalition that read
people united to save humanity the judge
will now ask anyone that enters the
gallery to not display their particular
opinion court is looking for 64 jurors
to advance to the next round
and convicted wife killer scott peterson
is denied bail as his defense team works
to secure him a new trial on wednesday a
judge ruled that peterson would stay
behind bars until his resentencing
hearing set for december as long crime
daily has reported the california
supreme court overturned peterson's
death sentence last year all this comes
years after peterson was convicted of
the murders of his wife lacey peterson
and their unborn son connor looking
forward peterson's legal team is now
working to secure their client a new
trial based on allegations of juror
misconduct from his 2004 trial a
california superior court judge is
expected to make that ruling and
peterson is due back in court on
november 10th to discuss whether his
appellate attorneys can continue to
represent him now that his case is no
longer involves the death penalty all
right so let's break this down nema talk
to me about that question about
peterson's attorneys the prosecution
argues he can't retain his attorneys
because this is no longer a death
penalty case but his lawyers from the
habeas corpus resource center say that
they should stay on what's likely to
happen
i think they likely will stay on they've
been working with him for so long
obviously you have special attorneys who
handle death penalty appeals the very
sort of
niche area of the law but ultimately
this is someone or team that's been
working on peterson's case for years
doesn't make sense to replace them have
someone start over and start
relitigating and relearning all these
issues i expect the people stay on terry
you know peterson spent the last 15
years in prison at san quentin do you
think that the judge correctly denied
his bail is he really that much of a
flight risk or danger
well i think the judge is probably
looking at the seriousness of this crime
he not only was convicted of killing his
wife but his unborn child as well so i
think that's part of the rationale
behind the judge's decision i don't
think there is a potential for a flight
risk but if you think about it he very
well might be thinking about how can i
just disappear so that possibility does
exist although it's a slight possibility
but i think the judge is probably just
thinking logically if the sentencing is
going to be life in prison and that's
going to happen in december then the
judge might be thinking well why let him
out now in a couple of months we're
going to sentence him to life he may as
well just sit in jail while he waits for
that sentencing well it's going to be a
pretty similar environment to what he's
seen in the last 15 years but having
said that who knows what's gonna happen
with scott peterson never thought we
would be saying his name again nima
romani terry austin thank you so much
and everyone out there thanks for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you